alors on a nous avons le plaisir de de
vous accueillir monsieur Baudouin
touvenau pour cette audition devant
notre commission d'enquête c'est
inspecteur général de la justice
directeur du bureau français d'unité de
coopération judiciaire de l'Union europé
européenne Eurojust et je vais commencer
par m'astreindre à vous
demander cette prestation de serment qui
vaut devant une commission d'enquête
parlementaire puisque je vous appelle
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission est passible de peine prévu
aux articles
434-13-1-1 du Code pénal je vais donc
vous inviter aprêt t serèement de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure je le jure cette obligation étant
satisfaite je vous laisse la parole et
puis après on aura un échange piloté par
notre rapporteur et mes collègues
sénatrices et sénateur est-ce que vous
me permettez de poser des questions
poser toutes les questions si si vous me
posez une questions vous ouvrez votre
micro pardon comme ça elle sera entendu
par ceux qui nous
regardent est-ce que V vos textes prévoi
que c'est la main
droite pour la prestation de
serment non non parce que dans les
textes de procédure pénal c'est on prête
serment on jure de dire toute la vérité
on lève la main mais on dit pas laquelle
donc je voulais savoir si dans vos
textes à vous il y avait une différence
par rapport de procédure pénale
mais non mais parce que je pense que si
vous voulez c'est la droite c'est la
main qui touche c'est une tradition on
lève cette je pense que c'est cellels
cette ouvertureette réfle voilà alors
premièrement une toute petite
remarque qui tient à mon titre ma
qualité parce que si vous rigà un
rapport je pense qu'il faut mettre je
suis en fait je suis membre national
pour la France à Eurojust et je ne suis
pas le directeur du bureau français mais
c'est c'est pas grave c'est simplement
dans un rapport comme vos rapports ont
toujours une bonne tenue quand je les ai
lu il sont toujours très intéressants il
vaut mieux mettre des choses concrètes
et on depuis 2000 depuis le 12 décembre
2019 nous sommes
l'Agence européenne de coopération
judiciaire et puis l'unité parce que
c'est tout l'intérêt de la dernière
régulation de de 2018 c'est que nous
sommes devenus véritablement une agence
européenne voilà à l'instar d'europo et
toutes les autres agences européennes
avec quand même des spécificités alors
je le dis parce que ça ça vaut je reste
un magistrat français je ne suis pas un
fonctionnaire européen voilà donc c'est
toute c'est la vraie différence entre la
entre Eurojust qui est composée si vous
voulez enfin je je vous décris un peu le
contexte pour que mise à disposition par
la France tout à fait c'est une mise à
disposition par la France mais conformé
conformément aux articles qui régissent
le membre nationale à Eurojust je reste
soumis à l'article 30 du code de
procédure pénale et j'ai si vous voulez
j'ai un mon statut est celui d'un
procureur général mais je reste soumis à
éventuellement des questionnements voir
des directive de la part du ministre je
ne suis pas un fonctionnaire européen
dépendant de la commission c'est
important à dire parce que c'est une
agence qui reste si vous voulez ce que
j'ai l'habitude de décrire comme puisque
ça ça va correspondre à la première
question en fait notre travail travail
de rejus c'est en fait de faciliter la
coopération pénale au niveau européen
entre tous les étatsmembres c'était
l'origine c'était ça mais pas uniquement
puisque nous sommes composés non
seulement de tous les pays de l'Union
européenne plus le Danemark avec
laquelle nous avons un accord
particulier puisque le Danemark par
référendum s'est retiré de toutes les
instances judiciaires et policières bon
donc on a un accord avec le Danemark qui
a une représentation Eurojust à cela
s'ajoute actuellement 12 autres pays
tiers à l'Europe en passant par les
États-Unis la Suisse la Norvège
énormément d'État balcaniques ce qui
fait qu'on est au total Eurojust 37 pays
d'accord ce qui fait ce qui me fait dire
quand je présente rapidement la l'agence
qu'on est un petit conseil européen
judiciaire c'est-à-dire que Conseil de
l'Europe comprenant 46 membres plus des
comment dirais-je des pas des
spectateurs mais des des membres un peu
extérieurs des observateurs merci là
nous on est 37 donc et on a un
fonctionnement les outils européen étant
UE plus la convention de 59 on a on a
des possibil ité de travail à Eurojust
avec 37 pays voilà je le dis parce que
quand on quand on passe Eurojust on
passe surtout à l'UE mais c'est pas que
l'UE c'est plus large voilà donc notre
travail l'objectif de l'agence qui a été
créé en
2002 un peu sur le modèle d'Europol je
pense que vous avez entendu monsieur
Jean-Philippe Lecouf voilà un peu sur le
modèle d'europo avec des bureaux
nationaux plus un staff je dirais plus
européen la différence sans doute avec
Europol entre Europol et Eurojust c'est
que la dimension nationale a pour moi
gardé une part très importante au niveau
d'Eurojust puisqu'en fait tout le
travail opérationnel pour la
facilitation de la coopération
européenne dans tous les domaines et pas
uniquement le narcotrafic est vraiment
effectué par les membres des bureaux
nationaux donc en pour le bureau
français on est en effectif théorique
comme diraient les militaires 5 et en
effectif réel 4 mais je ne désespère pas
puisque j'ai obtenu un 5è membre qu'on
soit bientôt à effectif 5 voilà donc
cinq magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire la majorité des gens
eurojustes proviennent principalement du
parquet je parle pour tous les pays en
ce qui me concerne je n'ai été que juge
d'instruction toute ma carrière
c'est-à-dire que j'ai fait 28 ans
d'instruction avant d'être le membre
national Eurojust et que j'étais
spécialisé depuis le début en
2004 GES puisque j'ai été Gears Paris
dès le début jusque 2017 avant que je re
jooigne Créteil comme doyen
voilà alors je vais essayer de répondre
à toutes vos questions vous souhaitez me
les poser ou je pense que c'est plus
c'est on gagnera du temps si je fais
spontanément vous faites spontanément
c'est une trame à essentielle puis après
toute façon tout ce que vous vous
n'aurez pas dit de manière liminire on
reviendra le chercher donc n'hésitez pas
très bien je pense avoir tout préparé
mais alors comme j'ai eu un problème
d'ordinateur je suis obligé de tourner
mes feuilles je suis encore un peu à la
galaxie
gutinbert même si on écrit de moins en
moins je me suis je me rends compte
d'ailleurs mais je que on écrit
tellement moins que en fait on écrit de
moins en moins bien pour compléter ma
réponse dans la mesure où vous allez
nous donner un écrit je pense que sur
l'oral vous pouvez aller à l'essentiel
et puis on reviendra sur les choses qui
vous paraent je vais à l'essentiel et je
n'ai pas oublié qu'il faut que je vous
envoie l'écrit pour le 5 février voilà
si j'ai bien lu toutes les consignes
pour reprendre tout à l'heure puisquon
parlait d'école j'ai bien lu les
consignes voilà donc notre rôle à nous
si vous voulez on agit globalement très
peu d'initiativ mais surtout à la
demande des autorités nationales
c'est-à-dire les magistrats qui nous
saisissent pour ouvrir un dossier
Eurojust voilà on dépossède pas les les
collègues qui ouvrent un dossier alors
n'importe
quel collègue magistrat puisqueen fait
il faut être une autorité judiciaire
pour pouvoir saisir Eurojust va nous
saisir d'une d'une difficulté soit de
coopération soit d'une volonté de
coordonner une la coopération alors on
est dans dans le sujet qui vous
intéresse c'est notre rôle est vraiment
de coordonner la coopération et d'être
le plus tôt dans les dossiers saisis
pour justement contacter tous les pays
et organiser avec eux la coordination de
de l'entraide pénale ce qui veut dire
que je ne décide pas dans le dossier du
collègue national je l'explique toujours
parce que pour que les choses soient
bien claires je ne suis plus je reste un
magistrat mais je ne suis plus une
autorité judiciaire au sens strict
c'est-à-dire que je n'interviens plus
dans les dossiers je suis là en support
des collègues nationaux qui euh souhaite
avoir des contacts plus approfondis avec
des pays de l'UE ou ceux que j'ai
contacté ou des pays tiers parce qu'on
peut organiser énormément de réunions
l'objectif étant de faciliter la
coopération ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que vont transiter par nous toutes
les demandes d'entraide les mandats
d'arrêts européens qu'on voudrait faire
exécuter et qui pose des difficultés
alors soit ça pose pas de difficultés
mais on est quand même au courant et on
intervient s'il y a des problèmes pour
avec des pays d'exécution notamment il y
a des questions qui sont évoquées sur
les différences juridique ou de
procédure qui existe entre les pays il
est clair que passer par Eurojust ça
permet d'anticiper ces difficultés
puisqueen fait même si je je vais pas
vous dire que je connais le droit
applicable dans les 26 dans les 27 pays
de l'UE c'est pas ça simplement
l'expérience fait puisque ça fait 4 ans
que je suis à aojust l'expérience fait
que on commence par connaître assez bien
pour chaque pays les difficultés qu'on
doit anticiper et les différences avec
notre droit à nous et là je prends le
parti de le dire dès le début je pense
qu'on a le droit on a la procédure
pénale qui offre pour l'instant le plus
de possibilités aux enquêteurs voilà et
et au juges d'instruction étant précisé
que juge d'instruction au procureur
étant précisé que sur le plan
international l'existence du juge
d'instruction est un plus je ne le dis
pas parce que j'ai exercé ça toute ma
vie pas uniquement vieille question
oui alors on pourra en discuter pendant
très longtemps
mais j'étais
convaincu sur le plan interne que ça
avait une utilité et j'en suis d'autant
plus convaincu sur le plan européen si
vous voulez c'est-à-dire que le juge
d'instruction est une personne qui
décide je vais faire court sur ça parce
que sinon je pourrais vous parler
jusqu'à 7 8h du soir le juge
d'instruction et l'autorité judiciaire
qui peut décider comme un magistrat du
siège et ça si vous voulez ça fait quoi
ça veut dire que quand un juge
d'instruction vient une réunion de
coordination quand il dit je vais faire
ça je vais faire telle perquisition tel
jour c'est pas la même chose qu'un
procureur dans un pays je sais pas en
Allemagne en lonie ou je ne sais quoi
qui va certes vous dire oui oui on va
faire ça mais qui va le demander à un
autre jug juge après si vous voulez
parce qu'il pourra pas leur donner
lui-même et donc là en matière de
coopération il est clair qu'avoir un
magistrat du siège qui en même temps
fait des enquêtes c'est essentiel voilà
or en fait on est globalement à part la
Belgique les seul le seul pays à garder
un juge d'instruction l'Espagne encore
un juge d'instruction mais c'est devenu
c'est un peu différent bon ben c'est
l'héritage napoléonien stiole petit à
petit donc il ne reste plus que la
Belgique et l'Espagne qui on à peu près
pas les mêmes systèmes que nous mais qui
permettent ça et quand l'enquête est
sous euh la direction d'un magistrat du
siège il a tous les pouvoirs dans les
mains voilà c'est c'est aussi simple que
ça voilà donc Eurojust 20 ans donc c'est
à la Hae ça je dis souvent que c'est un
peu la perle de l'Europe pour moi c je
fais la référence au tableau de Vermer
la jeune fille à la perle qui est à au
moritus mais pas uniquement pourquoi
c'est un peu la perle de l'Europe parce
que quand je l'ai je l'ai beaucoup
utilisé quand j'étais jus d'instruction
dès le début et en fait c'est sans doute
l'outil qui moi me paraît un des plus
pragmatiques de l'Union européenne voilà
justement parce qu'il mêle la réflexion
on a une partie réflexion mais on a
surtout une partie opérationnelle très
importante et les membres qui composent
le bureau français mais pas que le
bureau français sont en fait des vrais
magistrats de terrain qui soutiennent
leurs collègues au niveau européen et ça
ça nous fait une vraie pratique voilà
alors évidemment c'est je parle pas que
pour moi je parle pour les gens qui
travaillent avec
moi cette longue pratique que j'ai nous
permet d'être légitime auprès des
collègues français et d'avoir une vision
très pratique des dossiers c'est-à-dire
c'est pas de la étion si vous voulez
sous un an je ne dis pas fumeux mais je
dirais plus théorique c'est très
pratique parce que moi je l'ai pratiqué
pendant plus de 20 ans je suis un
Européen convaincu sur la coopération
sur la nécessité de la la coopération à
forceur dans ce type de dossier où en
fait il y a pas de vrai dossier de
narcotrafic sans coopération européenne
et au-delà à partir de là si vous voulez
ce qu'il faut c'est être à l'écoute des
collègues je ne décide pas leur place
mais avec l'expérience qu'on a en fait
on peut non pas les guider mais vraiment
les soutenir dans leur démarche de de
coopération pour arriver à la meilleure
chose voilà c'est ça l'objectif d' rjust
et c'est pour permettre ben on va être
très simple l'objectif quand vous mettez
ensemble moi j'en ai été convaincu dès
le début quand j'allais Eurojust et je
le vois tous les jours quand vous mettez
ensemble un espagnool un Suédois un Grec
un Danois au départ vous pensez qu'ils
vont pas ils vont pas obligatoirement
avoir les mêmes objectifs mais quand
vous mettez des enquêteurs et des
magistrats qui ont un objectif lutter
contre la criminalité organisée ensemble
ils arrivent toujours à se comprendre et
le maître notre travail c'est quoi c'est
un peu la phrase de Churchill when there
is will always a way quand il y a une
volonté il y a toujours un chemin et en
fait on trouve toujours le chemin parce
que l'Europe nous a fourni beaucoup
d'outils et qu'il faut connaître qu'il
faut mettre à la disposition on est
aussi des passeur d'outils de
coopération auprès de nos collègues
notamment en matière de certificat de
gel en matière de décision d'enquête
européenne et tout ça pour moi c'est
fabuleux je ne gère plus les dossiers en
premierers comme je le faisais mais
maintenant j'aide les autres à mieux les
gérer et j'ai un vraiment l'impression
de participer Eurojust pour ça est
exemplaire à vraiment une plus grande
sécurité européenne en évitant tous les
soucis puisque les voyou ne connaissent
pas de frontières il faut pas que les
magistrats en connaissent non plus voilà
ça c'est la première présentation mais
je peux répondre à toutes vos questions
si vous voulez sur Eurojust et je suis
prêt parce que je le propose à chaque
fois que j'interviens comme ça si une
délégation du Sénat veut un jour venir
visiter Eurojust en même temps
qu'Europol il y a pas de problème vous
êtes les bienvenus
euh des sessions d'information comme
cell-là sont pour moi toujours
l'occasion non seulement de présenter ce
qu'on fait mais de mieux vous informer
sur la nécessité quand vous entendez le
mot Eurojust après 1 non seulement vous
l'identifiez parce que vous m'avez vu
mais vous l'identifierez sur quelque
chose de très pratique et de très
opérationnel dans les
dossiers voilà alors je vais répondre à
la deuxième question vous considérez que
la première c'est bon ou vous me dites
ce que vous
voulez alors après les grandes tendances
si vous voulez de la principales
évolution récente du narcotrafic à
l'échelle de l'Europe alors là je pense
que Monsieur Lecouf a dû vous faire une
présentation en général Europol a plus
d'informations que nous pour une raison
fort simple c'est que à Eurojust nous
sommes normalement nous connaissons
normalement que les dossiers de très
grande
importance logiquement Europol reçoit
beaucoup d'information via Sienna donc à
des données différentes des notes nous
on voit la face plus importante de
l'iceberg mais qui représente pas tout
tout dépense que vous mettez sur le
narcotrafic moi à partir du narcotrafic
pour moi ça
c'est pas le trafic de rue on est bien
d'accord après je pense que repo a des
informations statistiques et des données
sur toutes les enquête en cours qui sont
sans doute plus complètes que les notes
et plus larges nous les tendances qu'on
voit sous l'angle judiciaire c'est deux
grandes tendances pour moi sur les
routes et sur le fonctionnement c'est
par voie maritime donc là les ports
alors effectivement là quand vous voyez
les grands ports concernés mais c'est
Hambourg Rotterdam envers si vous voulez
principalement c'est les plus gros ports
européens c'est les premiers concernés
alors évidemment c'est pas à vous que je
vais apprendre que le container est un
peu comment dirais-je le symbole si ce
n'est vivant mais métallique de la
mondialisation donc le ces trois grands
ports là aussi ça serait je pense que ça
peut être intéressant mais vous l'avez
peut-être déjà fait de visiter une fois
qu'on a visité Rotterdam on a un peu
compris le port de Rotterdam avec des
des kilomètres et des kilomètres de
container on comprend que le contrôle
complet est impossible envers c'est
pareil toute façon reter d'AM envers
c'est pas très séparé
euh là effectivement voie maritime donc
énormément de saisies puisque je crois
qu'en 2022 les Belges ont saisi 110
tonnes de cocaïne les Pays-Bas pareil
pourquoi parce que bah c'est le plus
simple il y a tellement de containers
vous cachez une tonne de cocaïne dans un
container où il y a plein d'autres
choses c'est plus compliqué à contrôler
bon avec tous les risques s entraîné
pour ces deux pays c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a jamais de criminalité organisé d'un
haut niveau s de la corruption derrière
alors corruption basse intensité jusqu'à
très haute intensité et je pense que les
Pays-Bas alors je vais essayer d'être
quand même politique correct ont un peu
euh n'ont pas nié le problème mais ne
l'ont pas regardé vraiment en face et il
y a fallu les catastrophes qu'il y a eu
avec une menace d'enlèvement d'une
princesse le Premier ministre un
journaliste tué un avocat aussi pour
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils étaient on va
pas dire à deux doigts de basculer comme
un narcra on est un narco-état on n'est
pas en Équateur on n'est pas en Colombie
on n'est pas au Venezuela mais néanmoins
que la la mocro mafia devenait quelque
chose de prignant et dangereux et je
pense qu'ils sont en train de changer
non pas leur
politique sur la dépénalisation de la
consommation parce que ça je pense
qu'ils reviendront pas dessus mais ils
sont en train de changer sans doute leur
vision de la criminalité organisée et
sans doute aussi leur moyen d'action
voilà euh les Belges c'est pareil et ce
qui a révélé tout ça les Belges enverse
si vous voulez je pense qu'ils ont fait
une opération main propre hein on n
parle pas comme si c'était en Italie
mais je pense qu'ils ont fait une
opération où ils ont nettoyé le port
parce que c'est pareil il y avait de la
corruption euh comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure le corollaire des gros trafics
des gros trafics de stupéfiants et plus
généralement de la criminalité organisée
c'est qu'il y a éor c'est qu'il y a de
la corruption il y a ça ne peut pas
fonctionner sans corruption alors après
les meilleurs moyens dans les ports de
lutter c'est ce que les Néerlandais je
pense vont essayer de mettre en place et
les les Belges aussi c'est de réduire le
facteur humain parce qu'en fait si vous
voulez quand vous importez enfin je
pense que vous le savez très bien mais
quand vous importez de la cocaïne dans
un container il y a a un moment il faut
quand même qu'il ait quelqu'un qui aille
chercher le container qui le mette un
peu de côté et qui puisse que des voyou
ou des trafiquants puissent venir
récupérer la drogue si vous arrivez à
retirer un maximum de manutention au
niveau des containers vous devz
normalement retirer un peu le facteur
humain voilà maintenant ce qui va se
passer c'est que si ces Pors deviennent
beaucoup plus sécurisé on risque d'avoir
en France c'est aussi pour ça que je
précise sur ce point on va avoir un
glissement c'est-à-dire que après si
vous voulez d'unquer qui est pas loin le
Havre non plus donc il y a déjà des
arrivées avec des bateaux qui passent au
Havre qui s'arrêtent au Havre qui monte
après en ver soit rdam on risque d'avoir
un report sur les ports français si
eux-mêmes sont pas complètement
bien comment dirais-je bien conscien
mais ils en sont conscients parce que
les autorités policières ou judiciaires
des ressorts en question savent bien que
si ça devient trop
dangereux dans les ports flamands plus
sur Hambourg ça va ça va se reporter un
peu sur la France avant et on a quand
même toute une zone atlantique si vous
voulez pour l'instant ça s'est pas fait
obligatoirement pour des raisons de la
quantité transportter mais les ports de
plaisance on a toute la façade
atlantique si vous voulez qui peut se
transformer aussi donc ça c'est un point
pour le narcotraphicque c'est un point
de
euh point d'attention qu'il faut avoir
et toute façon il y a pas besoin de de
c'est c'est déjà arrivé puisque
souvenez-vous en vendz ce qu'on a trouvé
avec les ballots qui arrivaient bon ça
c'est sans doute des gens qui allent
être contrôlés qui ont jeté à la mer
mais ça veut dire que les petits ports
de plaisance qu'il y a sur en vandé ou
sur toute la côte atlantique peuvent
devenir aussi le réceptacle sans doute
de moins grande quantité mais de
peut-être d'arrivage plus sécurisé donc
ça aussi c'est un point
d'attention ensuite alors on a alors il
y a il y a il y a des initiatives
françaises qui sont intéressantes au
niveau judiciaire c'est-à-dire que c'est
l'arc
méditerranéen la procureur générale
avait lancé un comment dirais-je un une
ce qu'on appelle une Tasque force mais
enfin bon une quelque chose de
judiciaire avec la Méditerranée
française Barcelone et sans doute avec
gène donc ça c'est intéressant qu'il y a
des initiatives locales et pas
uniquement globales euh la même la même
initiative a été pris par le procureur
général de Bordeaux qui a proposé toutes
les cours d'appel qui sont sur l'Arc
Atlantique donc ça va jusqu'à Rennes de
créer aussi là une Tasque force pour que
la France puisse avoir au niveau
judiciaire après ça se décline au niveau
policier euh prennent des initiatives ça
veut dire quoi tous ces groupes de
travail c'est là aussi c'est de
l'opérationnel c'est-à-dire que il faut
échanger pour
euh connaître mieux les les les
difficultés on peut faire face les
dossiers qu'on a après on échange
c'està-dire il faut combiner pour avoir
une meilleure connaissance il faut
effectivement échanger au plus
l'information
alors par voie aérienne on a encore du
transport vous ignoriez vous n'ignorez
pas non plus que depuis la Guyane il y a
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de cocaïne qui
arrivve ça avec énormément si on
contrôle tous les avions qui viennent de
de Cayen ben c'est compliqué
c'est-à-dire que il y a je pense que
j'ai travaillé à Créteil par un certain
nombre d'années c'est-à-dire que si on
poussait le le nombre de cellules de
garde à vue à Cayenne avant le départ ou
à l'arrivée je pense qu'on peut arriver
parfois avec la moitié des avions où il
y a des gens qui ont des quantités
certes minimes et puis en fait le
recrutement sur place c'est ce qu'on
vous a dit je pense mais bon ça ça reste
une réalité pourquoi parce que il y a
aussi une misère en Guyane avec des gens
qui sont du Surinam des gens qui sont à
Saint-Laurent du Maroni voilà c'est moi
j'ai je je cite un cas toujours quand
j'étais juge d'instruction à créteille
j'ai j'ai reçu une jeune femme qui
arrivait elle était à peine majeure bon
elle la nationalité française mais
j'étais obligé de prendre un interprète
parce qu'elle ne parlait pas le français
voilà donc à Saint-Laurent du Maroni
voilà ben oui et je je vais être franc
avec vous j'avais presque
honte parce que je de voilà on parle à
quelqu'un qui est censé qui a des
papiers français qui est parfaitement
français mais qui ne parle pas le
français donc qui n'est jamais all à
l'école donc ça c'est une vraie
difficult ça n'a que peu à voir avec le
sujet pour lequel j'interviens mais
c'est une réalité c'est-à-dire que
pardon bah c'est le substrat parce que
c'est la misère qui recrute c'est-à-dire
que si vous voulez je pense qu'en guyan
les trafiquants ils ont jamais aucune
difficulté ulté pour trouver quelqu'un
qui va prendre le risque de prendre la
viande voilà avec 500 g de de cocaïne
mais quand on connaît le prix de la
revente de la cocaïne par rapport au
prix où qu'elle vaut dans les Antilles
on fait une culbute infernale B on prend
un risque s'il y a 20 personnes qui
transportent la cocaïne dans un avion et
dans un vol et qu'il y en a deux qui
sont pris bah le reste c'est bon voilà
donc c'est une calcul du risque faut
jamais perdre de vue que surt ces trafic
certes la marchandise est illégale mais
le raisonnement commercial et le
raisonnement prise de risque elle M que
pour une substance légale hein
voilà alors
euh alors le vecteur terrestre pour
finir sur les routes et les produits en
fait si vous voulez c'est toujours un
peu le même c'est-à-dire qu'on a la
résine de cannabis c'est clair qu'elle
vient d'Espagne pourquoi parce qu'elle
vient du Maroc voilà
donc les Espagnols je pense sont noyés
sous les sous le trafic de stupéfiant
sur
l'arrivée donc en général là c'est soit
ce qu'on appelait communément des
goofast ou alors c'est parfois des
camions et l'héroïne quand elle arrive
arrive elle arrive des Balcans voilà ça
ça ça ça reste à peu près des
constantesin
euh alors effectivement s'agissant de la
drogue de synthèse il y en a en France
mais en fait on a un pays de transit
parce qu'elle est fabriquée
principalement au Pays-Bas en Belgique
alors je pense pas qu'on fasse rentrer
le trafic de cigarettes dans le
narcotrafic mais néanmoins le trafic de
cigarettes si vous voulez utilise les
mêmes vecteurs et intéresse beaucoup
certaines on retrouve les Georgiens on
retrouve geéorgien point d'alerte aussi
sur les vores et les voleurs dans la loi
geéorgien c'est-à-dire que il commence
d'après ce que j'ai compris il commence
à pas mal s'installer en France et le
jour où ils seront bien installés ça
sera compliqué voilà de les déloger
parce que je pense que pour
l'instant grâce à notre droit je crois
avec un droit qui qui reste très
puissant je pense à une procédure pénale
qui reste efficace si vous voulez on
arrive arrive à à juguler pas mal de
choses qui fait qu'il y a pas mal de
français d'un certain niveau dans le
narcotrafic qui ne reste pas en France
si vous voulez parce que la France n'est
pas un pays de sécurité pour les pour
les malfaisants voilà alors pour ça
c'est ce qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il faut
qu'on préserve aussi alors comme la
parole est libre je vais vous le dire
aussi de façon j'espère que la réforme
de la PJ ne va pas atténuer tout ceci
c'est-à-dire que la réforme de la police
judiciaire qui peut peut-être faire
porter plus les efforts de la police sur
comment dira des procédures de proximité
et tout il faut pas perdre de vu que le
crime organisé si on arrête la lutte un
petit peu on récupère plus après voilà
je pense que c'est c'est une vraie
difficulté donc la réforme de la PJ il
faut que la DC enfin ça s'appellera
maintenant la dnpj mais il faut qu'au
profit des Girs et de la junalco et des
jurridiction spécialisée il faut que la
lutte contre la criminalité reste tout
organisée reste un vrai objectif même si
j'ai conscience aussi par rapport au au
retour que vous pouvez avoir dans vos
circonscriptions que la criminalité
organisé c'est pas celle qui touche le
plus les particuliers ou les gens parce
que elle est
souvent ils en entendent parler mais en
fait ils ne la vivent pas au jour le
jour si vous voulez alors on la vit un
peu sauf peut-être dans la région de
Marseille mais pour le reste la grosse
délinquence organisée elle est assez
transparente pour nos concitoyens je
pense donc elle ne menace pas
directement au jour le jour l'ordre
public
voilà alors ensuite sur cette question
sur ça je pense que j'ai fait le tour
alors l'impact de la criminalité connexe
alors ça c'est clair que B j'ai déjà
parlé de la corruption le blanchiment va
avec hein parce que quand on manipule
énormément de sommes il est clair qu'à
un moment il faut les blanchir le vrai
enjeu sur le blanchiment maintenant ça
sera de s'intéresser je pense que le
système financier est à peu près bien
réglé mais ça sera il faudra
s'intéresser vraiment aux cryptoonnaaies
parce que c'est là où il faut sortir un
peu de l'image aussi que disons que les
narcotrafiquants sont idiots ils sont
non seulement pas idiots mais surtout
ils savent avoir recours à des
ingénieurs financiers pour leur faire
des choses plus compliquées donc ça sur
les cryptoonnaaies ça sera
important les règlements de comptte
effectivement alors là c'est vrai que
pour l'instant ce qu'on voit je parle
pas de l'Italie mais ce qu'on voit en
France ça touche surtout la le sud de la
France moi j'ai pas vu de dossier j'ai
vu à Eurojust des dossiers de règlement
de compte mais il ne concerne que pour
l'instant que la zone marseillaise si
vousz voilà alors bah l'impact de la
criminalité
connexe bah c'est surtout celui-là moi
ce que je vois c'est qu'il y a c'est le
blanchiment le blanchiment
constitue avec le trafic de stupéfiants
une
des un des domaines les plus importants
Eurojust en fait il y a rarement des
dossiers qui sont ouverts pour
stupéfiant sans qu'il y ait du
blanchiment parce qu'en fait si c'est un
dossier de stupéfiant important il y a
toujours du blanchiment derrière
il y a pas de il y a pas de hasard alors
après comme je dis le problème c'est
quand l'argent quitte l'Europe
c'està-dire que si on part et on y
reviendra sans doute à l'heure sur les
questions de pays avec lesquels c'est
plus compliqué en fait l'Europe est
parfois un rebond dans certains états et
après quand ça part soit en Chine soit à
Dubaï ou ailleurs c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué en Chine très
compliqué alors
ensuite est-ce que nous rencontrons des
difficultés dans la coopération avec ou
entre certains États-membres dans
l'exercice parus de ces missions
non pas avec les
États-membres une question d la poser
léirement pardon et il y a des pays qui
ne sont pas membres de l'Union
européenne et qui sont observateurs je
par de pays d'Afrique ou de pays d'Asie
et qui sont observateurs
ou est-ce que rejuste non alors
en fait les pays qui sont accueillis à
Eurojust hors UE sont des pays avec
lesquels nous avons des accords de
coopération c'est ça alors ça peut être
tout encore ça peut être n'importe quel
pays quand je dis n'importe jusqu'au
règlement de 2018 nous avions la
capacité de nous-même négocier ces
accords internationaux avec les États
concernés c'est comme ça qu'on a eu les
accords avec la Serbie qu'on a
eu la Serbie la geéorgie qui est
présente à EuroJ c'est bon et maintenant
depuis le règlement de 2018 c'est nous
proposons à la Commission européenne des
pays avec lesquels une liste de pays
tous les 4 ans avec lesquels nous
souhaiterions avoir des accords de
coopération les 10 pays pour lesquels
nous avons proposé a que la Commission a
accepté il y a la Colombie le Maroc il y
a tout le le pourtour européen la
Colombie le Maroc la Tunisie l'Algérie
le Liban je pense que c'est en très
bonne voie d'être conclu avec l'Arménie
voilà donc ces pays-là on aura un accord
de coopération alors
euh ça renvoie directement à la
convocation que j'avais avec la
protection des données qui étaaient
mentionné en bas nous aussi on est
soumis à l' rgpd donc on a on a les
mêmes questions donc les échanges les
les accords de travail si vous voulez
qu'on conclue sont aussi pour les les
échanges de données personnelles avec
les pays-tiers parce que il vous aura
pas échappé que certains pays on n' pas
trop envie d'échanger des données
personnelles avec parce qu'on sait pas
bien ce que ça peut être donc les
accords de coopération ça veut dire
qu'on va travailler avec eux quasiment
comme des pays européens qu'on pourra
échanger des données sans difficulté il
appartient après à ces pays s'il le
souhaite d'envoyer à Eurojust qu'on
appelle un procureur de liaison
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un mag un ou
plusieurs magistrats du pays qui sont
présents à Eurojust c'està-dire que là
par exemple pour vous donner un exemple
très Simp nous avons deux norvégiens
deux Suisses deux
Américains qui sont là une serbe une
Ukrainienne hein parce que l'Ukraine est
présente à Eurojust avit un accord de
coopération et donc il sont elle est
présente là et donc on a on a qui est
arrivé donc on a une douzaine de
magistrats en plus des autres pays voilà
qui fait une
agence over pas lo ça ouvre des
possibilités àèes après on a peut toute
façon coopérer avec des pays
complètementers les invit à des réunions
après la vraie question c'est simplement
l'ch
de que j'ai répondu à très bien parfait
parfait alors je vais continuer donc
est-ceon a des difficultés avec les
États-membres non en fait on a on a pas
de difficultés au
sens la
coopération la la coopération il y a
deux aspects il y a
les les textes les outils qui la
permettent et puis après il y a les
hommes qui servent de ces outils les
hommes et les femmes qui se servent de
ces outils voilà bon c'est un peu pareil
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes donc
effectivement on peut parfois avoir des
difficultés ne relève pas de certains
étatsin alors il est courant de dire
dans les enceintes quand on parle de
coopération c'est compliqué avec
l'Angleterre oui alors l'Angleterre
c'était parfois compliqué ça ne tient
pas aux anglais ça tient alors aux
différences de culture juridiqu qui
peuvent exister entre nous et les
Anglais le fait qu'ils aient le brexit
n'a rien changé à cette difficultés
puisqu'ils n'ont pas changé leur droit
si vous voulez et qu'on a trouvé en plus
je pense que
des l'accord a permis de trouver des
outils
de des outils de coopération nouveaux
qui maintiennent quelque chose qui peut
être qui peut fonctionner avec
l'Angleterre pour pour prendre une
comparaison qui n'est peut-être pas
raison mais qui est lié au système la
coopération n'est pas simple non plus
avec l'Irlande or l'Irlande fait partie
de l'UE c'est pas plus simple pourquoi
parce que c'est des des systèmes et des
histoires juridiques différentes pour le
reste avec les autres pays de l'Union
européenne nous n'avons pas
particulièrement de
difficultés après il y a des différences
c'est ça notre richesse à Eurojust c'est
justement de confronter toutes ces
différen donc effectivement quelque
chose qui est possible en France n'est
pas obligatoirement juridiquement
possible en Allemagne sans prendre des
pays plus lointain voilà les écoutes
téléphoniques sont possibles dans
beaucoup de cas en France elles ne le
sont pas toujours en Allemagne voilà
c'est aussi simple donc les différences
c'est ça les difficultés c'est qu'il
faut que les collègues acceptent ça
suppose une certaine humilité que c'est
pas parce qu'on est en France qu' on va
faire comme en France parce que c'est
pas possible dans les autres pays
donc d'ailleurs je je
comme le temps passe et qu'on ve Gard un
petit peu de temps pour les questions je
pense que la deuxème partie sur les
évolutions normatives européennes et les
quelques pistes de réflexion peut peut
vraiment être crucial pour nous c'est
sans doute donc si si on peut aller vers
ce ces aspects là je pense que c'est
simplement à la
question
en précise étant préciser que je suis
favorable pu je finirai là-dessus moi au
sein d'Eurojust pour qu'en fait nous
envoyons des magistrats de liaison
européen c'est-à-dire que je pense que
là où l'Europe il faut que l'Europe
judiciaire elle parle à certains pays ou
à certaines régions et je pense que dans
la dans la péninsule arabique en fait ça
serait pas abérrent que on a alors c'est
pareil j'ai rien contre les dipl bien
évidemment je crois qu'il faut que ça
soit des gens de terrain qui aient des
contacts avec certains pays comme nous
on l'a au travers des magistrats de
liaison moi il y a des pays la Finlande
par exemple a déjà demandé est-ce que le
magistrat de liaison français qui est
qui est compétent au Maroc pour
intervenir pour nous donc si vous voulez
il y a un besoin le besoin il est pas
même avec Dubaï l'extradition on en aura
mais il y a plein de pays qui ont les
mêmes besoins ils peuvent pas envoyer un
magistrat donc je pense qu'à un moment
sur ces questionsl faudra que l'Europe
mutualise et c'est c'est un point de vue
très personnel
ensuite est-ce que j'ai déjà vu des en
raison des divergences avec les règles
de procédure pénal des États-membres des
procédures tombées non parce que c'est
tout le travail de rejus c'est justement
d'éviter que il y ait des difficultés et
il y a pas de nullité lié aux
divergences parce que je crois que ce
qu'on conçoit comme difficulté
c'est-à-dire que ça va pas permettre de
travailler comme on le fait en France
c'est de faire les mêmes choses que ce
qu'on ferit en France mais c'est pas des
divergences qui sont source de nullité
puisque quand on exerce en mare quand on
effectue de la coopération qu'on demande
des actes à un autre pays en fait il y a
le principe de la loi du fort qui
s'applique c'est-à-dire que le pays va
exécuter votre demande d'entraite selon
ses propres règles nationales ce qu'on
ferait nous donc a priori si vous voulez
je
vois je vois pas où peut être le
problème d'une nulité pour moi il y en a
pas dès lors qu'on arrive à se
coordonner mais vous avez peut-être des
précisions qui me permettrai de réagir
plus sur cette
question euh alors le le rôle du
l'apport du réseau européen de lutte
contre la cybercriminalité si vous
voulez c'est un lieu de rencontre et
d'échange très important entre les les
spécialistes des différents pays dans
les diff dans les qui qui sont désignés
par des autorités nationales alors ça
peut être soit par exemple pour la
France ça peut être quelqu'un qui
appartiendra au parquet de Paris et la
section J3 qui est spécialisé sur la
cybercriminalité plus quelqu'un du
ministère de la Justice il se rencontre
une ou deux fois dans l'année tous donc
ça leur permet d'échanger et normalement
on va créer eurjust c'est même sûr qu'on
va le créer il y aura un secrétariat
pour pour ce réseau de européen de lutte
contre la cybercriminalité c'est-à-dire
qu'il y aura un secrétariat constant
Eurojust comme on a déjà pour le le
réseau génocide et autres et en fait
d'avoir un secrétariat Eurojust ça
permet quoi ça
permet déjà de faire beaucoup plus
d'action en terme de formation et ça
permet aussi
euh d'émettre et d'éditer des documents
de travail voilà donc avec toute la
réflexion de tous les membres et quand
on met ensemble des magistrats qui
traitent la même matière
euh en général ils ont des bonnes idées
ensemble et ça peut être un bon retour
pour vous aussi après parce qu'ils
constatent soit les mêmes difficultés
avec certains outils européens soit des
difficultés dans certains pays et à ce
titre on va parler demain à Eurojust en
fait de la Constitution aussi d'un
réseau de procureurs et de juge pour le
CR pour la lutte contre la criminalité
organisée parce qu'en fait voilà pour
professionnaliser aussi et que les gens
se voient entre eux étant préciser que
ces cénacles sont parfois l'antichambre
à l'ouverture de dossiers européens
Eurojust pourquoi parce que les gens se
voient ils ont les mêmes problématiques
et en fait entre eux ils vont dire bah
ça serait peut-être à toi d'ouvrir une
procédure donc on va ouvrir on va
inviter les autre elle pour le par
exemple pour les crimes contre
l'humanité le le genocide Network a été
euh su SAS pour justement ouvrir des
dossiers européens où les gens se sont
vus avant avant de lancer les choses et
de se dire on a un peu les mêmes
problématiques on va essayer de faire
quelque chose pour le pour le la la
cybercriminalité c'est un peu la même
chose et ça le sera pour le crime
organisé voilà
alors le rôle
d'eurjust dans le contre le blanchiment
mais le rôle d'eurjust contre le
blanchiment il est je dirais le même que
pour toutes les infractions pour
lesquelles eurjust peut agir étant
préciser qu'il y a quasiment toutes les
infractions possibles on peut être saisi
dès lors que plusieurs pays sont
concernés ou qu'il y a un vrai intérêt
pour le pays en question donc le
blanchiment comme je l'ai expliqué tout
à l'heure est quasiment tout le temps
adosser sur des dossiers de criminalité
organisée sauf exception et qu'est-ce
qu'on apporte comme plus alors les
outils de rejus je les présenter en 2
secondes c'est souvent mettre les gens
ensemble faire des réunions de
coordination faire des journées d'action
alors vous avez dans la deuxème partie
oui vous parlez des centres de
coordination centre de coordination
c'est une cellule de crise judiciaire en
matière de coopération lorsque les
interpellations ont lieu dans un de
façon coordonnée dans plusieurs pays on
crée un centre de crise judiciaire qui
coordonne tous les besoins bon ça je
pourrais vous en parler tout
l'après-midi mais on aura pas le temps
donc au travers de des dossiers ce qu'on
fournit aussi si vous voulez c'est
effectivement tout un toute une analyse
des dossiers judiciaires qu'on peut
soutenir pour les collègues avec on a
des outils d'analyse alors qui ne qui ne
sont pas comment dirais-je ce n'est pas
contraire à au travail fait par Europol
ça peut être complémentaire c'est autre
chose moi je trou je conçois le travail
Jean-Philippe Lecouf que je connais bien
nous sommes sur la même longueur d'onte
il y a pas de normalement il doit pas y
avoir de lutte entre les deux agences si
vous voulez il doit y avoir
complémentarité dans le respect du rôles
de chacun l'autorité judiciaire la
police tout ça doit fonctionner tous les
budgets européens et autres doivent être
dépensés dans l'intérêt des deux agences
et surtout de la sécurité
européenne alors le les paiements
liquide ou le dépôt d'argent liquide sur
des comptes bancaires je serais tenté de
dire
que c'est bien quand il le dépose sur
des comptes bancaires parce qu' on voit
qu'il y a l'argent dessus si vous voulez
ça laisse des traces donc on est un peu
loin de ça je pense maintenant on est
passé à quelque chose d'autre et que
toute façon il y a soit des réseaux
complètement secret où on nacccepte pas
le blanchiment avec les comment
dirais-je les crypto les monnaai
dématérialisé tout ça est beaucoup plus
important que le dépôt ou l'achat avec
1000 € 10000 € quand est-ce qu'on est
obligé de faire un chèque parce qu'en
fait tous ces gens si vous voulez les
réquisitions bancaires classiques je
dirais ne servent quand même plus à
grand-chose hein le trafiquant qui
mettrait beaucoup d'argent sur son
compte ça serait quasiment une
circonstance
atténuante je je plaisante mais c'est n
plus
vraiment on est un peu au-delà de tout
ceci euh alors définir unifier la
définition de la criminalité organisée
au niveau européen si vous voulez la
criminalité organisée c'est c'est plutôt
une c'est plutôt comment
dirais-je une notion de criminologie qui
a des conséquences juridiques donc je
pense que la criminalité organisée en
France on peut on peut la définir
criminologiquement il y a des critères
mais est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui
doit être défini au niveau européen tout
dépend si quand j'ai lu la question je
me suis dit est-ce que on est en train
de parler de l'association de
malfaiteurs ou est-ce qu'on est en train
de parler du concept qu'est-ce qui est
de la criminalité organisée si vous
voulez la criminalité organisée elle
fait déjà l'objet entre guillemets de de
définition dans les conventions
internationales et autres moi je ne
pense pas qu'on en ait
besoin qu'on ait besoin d'une définition
au niveau européen si c'est une ition
européenne de l'association de
malfaiteurs je ne suis pas convaincu
alors là aussi je il faudra il faudrait
qu'on adopte une définition
l'association de malfaiteurs qui soit
peut-être plus proche du système italien
o en fait c'est l'appartenance à la
mafia qui permet dès lors qu'on prouve
que vous appartenez à un groupe mafieux
c'est une infraction circulé il a rien à
voir après vous avez d'autres pays j'ai
eu notamment les discussions soit avec
l'Allemagne soit avec les Suisses leur
association de malfaiteur est beaucoup
plus stricte que la nôtre voilà donc on
n'est pas moi c'est compliqué de pour
moi je pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'on
reste sur nos cultures propre sur
certaines définitions en fait ce qu'il
faut l'intérêt de la coopération
européenne et des outils européens c'est
de créer une cohérence c'est pas
obligatoirement de créer une uniformité
voilà mais ça aussi c'est moi qui parle
c'est pas le ministère de la
Justice alors le rapport de rejus sur le
trafic de drogue en 2021 indique que
malgré des résultats positifs
prometteurs obtenu par les centres de
coordination alors je vous ai expliqué
les centres de coordination c'est une
cellule de crise comme si on était tous
là chacun d'entre vous représente un
pays et on a décidé lors de réunion de
coordination antérieurement de faire une
action commune c'est-à-dire de d'arrêter
les gens ou de faire des perquisition
dans tous les pays concernés ici donc on
est une petite douzaine et puis on
décide de les faire à la même heure bon
alors tout ça suppose aussi je ne vous
le cachache pas une belle coordination
parce qu'effectivement les heures de
perquisition les heures légales de
perquisition ne sont pas les mêmes
partout donc il faut parfois trouver
plus petit d'nominateur commun mais
c'est ça aussi la négociation européenne
et après ce jour-là euh on met tout le
monde ensemble et par exemple
j'interpelle quelqu'un chez vous vous
m'indiquez vous êtes on va dire que vous
venez d'Allemagne et donc vous
m'indiquez qu'en Allemagne les trois
personnes qui étaient visées ont été
arrêtées les perquisitions donnent tel
résultat mais que par exemple oui sauf
qu'il y a un nouvel endroit qui est à
perquisitionner qui était pas prévu donc
là les
Allemands demandent une nouvelle
décision d'enquête européenne pour
procéder à la perquisition donc tout
l'intérêt c'est de le savoir
immédiatement de pouvoir le répercuter
au collègues voir c'est ce que j'ai fait
une fois j'ai le pouvoir en cas
d'urgence de faire moi-même les es comme
membre national mais c'est ça arrivé une
fois je suis le seul à l'avoir fait et
après pareil pour les certificat gel si
vous voulez ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
fait au niveau européen sur les ces
journées d'action on fait un point
toutes les heures avec les collègues
tout ce qui se passe au niveau européen
et on le transmet aux collègues français
alors que lui en même temps si vous
voulez a 10 gardes à vu à contrôler bon
peut pas s'occuper de tout ça on fait
des réunions en direct en visio pour
régler tous les problèmes voilà on est
un peu on est des facilitateurs des
goben et des got trou tout de la
solution européenne voilà en matière de
coopération donc les centres de
coordination comment elle peut être
favorisée bah c'est très simple he
c'est-à-dire bon faut pas non plus tuer
une mouche avec un marteau c'est-à-dire
que ça c'est quand même quelque chose
qui demande une grosse préparation ça
doit pas s'appliquer à des dossiers ça
doit s'appliquer à des dossiers qui le
méritent voilà très lourd et donc
comment les favorise ben c'est très
simple hein quand on prévoit les dates
pour faire la journée d'action commune
en fait faut toujours proposer de faire
un centre de coordination il y a des
collègues qui oublient de le proposer
dans d'autres bureaux c'est pas notre
cas on le propose à chaque fois parce
que le centre de coordination et là
aussi on va faire non pas du French Bing
mais du French support c'est nous qui
l'avons créé d'accord à Eurojust c'était
le bureau français j'y étais pas mais au
départ ça a été créé tout le monde
disait ça sert à rien c'est que pour les
policiers les trucs de crise final
finement maintenant on en a fait au
moins 150 et dans les nouveaux bâtiments
de rejuste on a même une salle prévue
exprès pour faire ce genre de chose que
je vous présenterai puisque je suis sûr
que vous viendrez nous voir
voilà alors les textes européens visant
à faciliter le gel des avoirs criminels
sont en cours de discussion
effectivement il y en a deux en fait en
fait pour revenir à un background plus
complet il y a la Commission a proposé
un un package complet de qure qure
règlements ou directives en 202
et pour l'instant il y en a deux qui ont
été discutés al c'est du très frais
puisqueen fait le 12 décembre à la
première il y a une directive concernant
la confiscation et le recouvrement des
avoirs ils sont parvenus à un accord
politique entre le Conseil et le
Parlement européen donc ça devrait
pouvoir tourner ils sont arrivés à un
accord
donc la nouvelle directive donc qui
devrait en découler quand je dis 12
décembre c'est 2023 un nouvelle
directive va mettre en place un ensemble
de règles minimum pour le traçage
l'identification le gel la confiscation
et la gestion des avoirs criminels
euh ça devrait si tout fonctionne ça
devrait permettre d'amplifier les
capacités des États-membres justement en
matière de lutte elle va s'appliquer
euh non seulement au crime organisé mais
également au terrorisme euh elle va
créer des obligations pour les
États-membres alors c'est-à-dire que il
faut bien voir que vous savez ce que
c'est la grâce tous les États-membres
n'ont pas encore d'agence de
recouvrement des avoirs criminels et de
gestion donc ça c'est encore c'est un
vrai travail parce que le jour où il y
aura ça ça sera effectivement la grasque
c'est c'est je pense que vous entendrez
le directeur ou la directrice de la
grasque c'est une
agence formidable la grasque voilà donc
je permets de le dire donc on va
l'Europe contrôlera que tous les pays
ont les moyens alors humains techniques
et autres de d'avoir ces agences sans
doute plus de pouvoirs devrait être
accordé aux agences pour le recouvrement
et dans le sens d'une meilleure
coopération c'est-à-dire qu'on pourra
aussi prévoir que les différentses les
différentes agences entre elles puissent
coopérer sur la gel et la confiscation
euh l'objectif c'est que vraiment de
favoriser le gel mais ça ça existe déjà
c'est un peu euh redondant permettre la
saisie en valeur alors la saisie en
valeur c'est possible en France c'est
pas possible dans tous les pays euh
c'est-à-dire l'équivalent quand vous
arrivez à prouver que le trafic a
produit temps vous pouvez saisir
l'équivalent euh dans un en valeur
c'est-à-dire soit un immeuble même si
l'immeuble n'a pas été acheté avec
l'argent des stupéfiants par exemple euh
quelque chose qui pourrait être étendu
mais qui ne l'est pas qui n'existe pas
dans tous les pays mais que nous avons
en France c'est la saisie générale du
patrimoine des gens euh comme peine
complémentaire dès lors que pour le le
trafic de stupéfiant des lor à peine
encouru est égal à 10 ans on peut saisir
tout le patrimoine sans rechercher s'il
y a a un lien avec le trafic de
stupéfiants voilà alors évidemment le
principe de proportionnalité toujours
soutenu par la Cour de cassation
s'applique c'est-à-dire que si dans le
trafic on a l'impression que ça porte
sur 100000 € on va pas pouvoir saisir un
un appartement avenue Montaigne qui
vaudrait 5
millions voilà alors aussi alors la
possibilité de saisir entre les tiers
enfin c'est des directives qui mon avis
vont étendre les capacités de
confiscation et de saisine pour
résumer et on prévoirait aussi puisse
faire alors ce qui existe dans certains
pays c'est-à-dire que soit parce qu'on a
lancé une enquête pénale mais qui n'a
pas abouti qu'on puisse arriver à des
saisies quand même alors civil
confiscation certains pays ont en
parallèle même si l'enquête pénale
n'aboutit pas je sa pas imaginer le
trafiquant im Meur extinction de
l'action publique bon néanmoins on avait
saisi des choses mais à ce moment-là on
pourrait sans doute quand même les
saisir les confisquer même si l'enquête
pénale arriverait n'arriverait pas à son
terme on va créer il devrait être créé
aussi par par cette directive ce qu'on a
déjà un peu en France c'est-à-dire
permettre le confisc la confiscation des
enrichissements inexpliqués c'est-à-dire
que ce qu'on a en France par exemple
c'est un nonjustification de ressources
ou par exemple quelqu'un qui vit avec un
trafiquant et qui a des maisons en
général il peut pas justifier ses
ressources c'est bon pour aller saisir
là on devrait pouvoir arriver à ça aussi
euh alors que je vous dise encore autre
chose alors bon il va y avoir sans doute
des garanties procédurales bien
évidemment ce qui devrait arriver aussi
c'est qu'on devrait
pouvoir
procéder partout en Europe à la vente
avant jugement des biens saisis parce
que ça on peut le faire en France
notamment quand les biens sont
périssables si vous vous saisissez une
maserratie vous saisissez un voilier on
pourra le vendre avant jugement il y a
beaucoup de pays en Europe où ce n'est
pas possible alors j'ai on a trouvé des
des subterfuges on a demandé par exemple
le Portugal ne peut pas le faire ils
avaient saisi pour nous un voilier qui
avait transporté de la drogue en fait il
on pouvait pas faire de certificat de
gel et autoriser la vente avant jugement
mais je leur ai demandé de le faire par
commission relatoire internationale ils
l'ont fait mais normalement ces
directives là devrai amener à une
similarité sur toutes ces questions
parce que c'est ça qui comptein parce
que parfois on peut faire des choses en
France mais si on les demande de faire à
l'étranger on va pas pouvoir le faire
voilà donc là il faut avoir ce que
j'appelit tout à l'heure une cohérence
on narrivera jamais et peut-être que
c'est pas un objectif à atteindre à ce
que tout le monde est exactement le même
droit mais il faut que entre les règles
posées par la CG les règles posées par
la CEDH et les outils européens on ait
une cohérence entre nos systèmes pour
pouvoir agir de façon si ce n'est
identique au moins similaire et
compréhensible entre nous voilà en
principalement
après il y a d'autres il y a ils ont
créé aussi l'autorité antibléchiment qui
va exister au niveau européen qui
devrait coordonner sans doute aussi
toutes les actions des des les unités
d'intelligence financière c'est-à-dire
l'équivalent tracf puisquil y en a ça
par contre il y en a dans pas mal de il
y en a pas mal de de pays dans de pays
et l'autorité européenne antiblanchiment
devrait pouvoir aussi coordonner
l'activité de ces unités à supposer que
chacun accepte d'être coordonnés puisque
c'est quand même ils appartiennent au
renseignement ils acceptent d'être
coordonnés mais ça devrait pouvoir se
faire ça c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne bien en terme de blocage des
comptes et autres par exemple en matière
de lutte antiblanchiment je pense que
Tracfin et les autres autor du même type
au niveau européen arrive à bloquer des
comptes quand il y a des suspicis alors
c'est un blocage administratif qui peut
pas durer parce qu'il doit être repris
judiciairement mais en urgence ça permet
de fonctionner et c'est ça qu'il faut
garder à l'esprit aussi quand on quand
on raisonne en matière de lutte contre
la criminalité organisée c'est qu'il
faut trouver la la bonne balance entre
préserver les droits fondamentaux des
gens sans nier les nécessités de la
lutte et c'est toujours un équilibre
alors c'est la même chose si vous voulez
quand on a aborde si on aborde les les
solutions cryptées et autres les
atteintes à la vie privée oui il faut
trouver un équilibre voilà après il
appartient au législateur de européen ou
national de trouver cet
équilibre alors ensuite alors les
enquêteurs français sont émus d'une
limitation des accès aux données de
connexion lié entre autres à la
jurisprudence cgue alors la cgue si vous
voulez il y a eu deux arrêts mais il y
en a un qui c'est surtout l'arrêt
l'arrêt HP je pense qu'il est 2022 en
fait ce qui dit c'est que parce que la
cgue elle dit pas euh par exemple le
droit français est pas conforme hein si
vous voulez ce qu'elle dit la cgue par
exemple c'est qu'elle a amené à traiter
des celle qui statuent sur les outils
européens qu'on utilise et ce qu'elle a
dit dans cet arrêt-là elle a dit que par
exemple un procureur français ne peut
pas demander dans le casadre d'une
décision d'enquête européenne des
données de géolocalisation ou de
téléphonie à un autre État pourquoi
parce qu'il n'est pas il n'est pas un
magistrat du siège il n'est pas un jug
voilà ce qu'elle a dit ce qui veut dire
que pour moi en drit drit interne pour
l'instant je pense que la Cour de
cassation l'a dit un procureur dans des
peut demander quand même ses données de
géolocalisation je pense que et là je je
peux comprendre les mois des policiers
mais les enquêteurs français quand ils
viennent à eurjust pour des réunions si
vous voulez quand il voit le droit
applicable dans certains autres pays
quand je me regarde je m'inquiète quand
je me compare je me
rassure voilà donc je crois que
là-dessus on est on a encore des moyens
d'action c'est ça que je veux dire on en
a encore on a une procédure qui
est que les autres pays nous envient
alors je cite parfois des
exemples des exemples je sais pas moi
les anciens pays du bloc soviétique si
vous voulez ont connu effectivement un
balancier différent par exemple une
surveillance physique en Lettonie mais
il faut une autorisation du juge tous
les mois c'est-à-dire pour faire une
filature si vous voulez bon en France on
reçoit ça on comprend pas hein parce que
les policiers ils ont l'initiative de le
faire sous le contrôle des magistrats
voilà donc ça va tout à l'avenant en
Allemagne les écoutes téléphoniques pour
plein de raisons ne sont pas sont
beaucoup plus compliqués qu'ells ne le
sont en France voilà en fait al les
écoute téléphonique c'est une chose et
on y viendra sur le ce qui compte
maintenant aussi dans la lutte contre la
criminalité organisée c'est vraiment la
dernière question hein le
13 les les la téléphonie cryptée si vous
voulez alors je pense que quand on on
pose cette question là on parle de
encrochat on parle de
Sky je suppose que ça ça ça se trouve en
source libre la position de rejust sur
ce sujet elle est très simple c'estàd
qu'on a été au cœur de la coopération
sur ces deux dossiers puisque pour vous
donner tout est publique ici ou pas oui
bon très bien c'est bien ce que j'avais
lu si vous voulez par exemple le dossier
Sky il a il a généré pour le bureau
français que je dirige en fait 2500
entre 2500 et 3000 demandes d'entr des
autres pays d'accord pour obtenir toutes
les données que la France avait capté
donc là nous avons le système juridique
pour capter ces données la vraie
difficulté qui peut se poser parfois et
c'est pour ça qu'on a dans ces deux
dossiers recours à d'autres pays aussi
c'est les les difficultés technique du
décryptage donc ça suppose là des
données d'avoir des capacités techniques
en matière de cyber voilà de décryptage
d'avoir les donc ça c'est un enjeu la
cybercriminalité c'est un vrai enjeu
parce qu'en fait derrière la
cybercriminalité il y a effectivement ce
dont on entend parler le plus souvent
les ramsware c'estàdire que les gens
alors ça touche aussi les les établiss
public puisque vous avez des des hackurs
qui se mettent dans je sais pas
l'hôpital d'éverie ou je ne sais où puis
qui après demandent une rançon pour mais
c'est pas que ça c'est-à-dire que toute
la téléphonie cryptée et la
cybercriminalité ça touche aussi le
narcotrafic parce que c'est leur moyen
les deux dossiers que j'évoquéis si vous
voulez ont montrer qu'en fait il y a pas
les gros trafiquants ils utilisent t
tous des solutions cryptées hein
c'est-à-dire que les écoutes
téléphoniques plus classiques si vous
voulez c'est c'éta pas encore obsolè je
je pas je n'ai pas dit ça mais c'est
vrai qu'après il faut passer à des
mesures comme la sonorisation
d'appartement de maison et tout parce
que voilà il faut qu'on s'adapte et ça
fait maintenant plus de 30 ans que je
suis magistrat mais c'est toujours la
même course c'està-dire que on est un
peu derrière on rattrape sky encrochaty
on a rattrapé ça a permis de donner je
pense que Jean-Philippe lecouff et
d'autres ont dû vous
donner plus un retour aussi sur ces
questions ça a donné une cartographie de
la criminalité organisée européenne
qu'onimaginait pas hein parce que là on
les avait en direct et comme ils étaient
sûrs d'être cryptés ils se lâchaient
c'est-à-dire qu'ils envoient des photos
ils expliquent tout enfin ils font y a
un côté heureusement les voyou sont
parfois un peu comment dirais-je
orgueilleux prétentieux donc quand ils
sentent euh tranquille là il se Lage
donc là on voit bien cartographie donc
des moyens qu'ils ont euh de la
dangerosité hein puisque les Hollandais
ont aussi les Néerlandais pardon ont
aussi euh changé leur point de vue quand
ils ont découvert que dans des
containerses à Rotterdam il y avait des
salles de torture hein pour les
enlèvements les séquestrations entre
bandes rivales qui évidemment personne
ne vient porter plainte donc c'est un
peu un chiffre noir sur les règlements
de compte quand il y a pas de mort qui
reste sur place il y a plein d'autres
faits de violence de pression auquel on
accète très peu puisquil est quand même
bien rare qu'un voyou viennent porter
plainte parce que si lui-même est
victime voilà donc tous ces dossiers là
ont donné une
vision assez complet de la criminalité
européenne et beaucoup plus que ça voilà
alors il faut laisser du temps aux
questions monsieur le Président donc
merci notre rapporteur
j'avais une question sur les procédures
d'infiltration et le recours au
repenti il y a une harmonisation qui est
prévue et vous travaillez sur ce
sujet-là alors ce qui est prévu c'est
qu'on il y a pas d'harmonisation au sens
triit c'est clair il y a pas
d'harmonisation par contre les outils de
coopération per par parce que il y a
aujourd'hui des différences très
substantielle entre le droit italien
notamment qui a été inspiré par la lutte
antimafia et le droit des autres États
ouais il y a des vraies différences ou
et c'est surtout en fait si vous voulez
les différences notamment avec l'Italie
elles tiennent aussi à une beaucoup plus
grande expérience et une vraie culture
du phénomène si vous voulez donc
l'infiltration je pense qu'en France ENF
j'ai fait les j'ai fait les premières
légales en 2004 si vous voulez je pense
qu'on la pratique pas assez
l'infiltration parce que c'est quelque
chose qui coûte très cher il faut des
vrais moyens in les repentis c'est
pareil je pense que le système des
repentis doit être tendu parce que la
lutte contre la criminalité organisée
tel que moi je peux le voir ce qui se
passe en Italie si vous voulez c'est
vraiment les deux accents elle est
repenti beaucoup il est repenti le
système moi je vais pas parler je pense
que si vous interrogez Marc somerer qui
est le président de la commission sur
les repentis pourra peut-être vous en
dire plus je pense que j'en ai peu vu
moi dans ma dans ma carrière le système
existe je pense qu'il doit encore être
amé amélioré je sais pas comment et
c'est surtout qu'il faut qu'on change un
changement de paradigme sur C question
et c'est exactement la même chose
alors sur les parce que système repenti
infiltration pour moi on peut pas
aborder non plus ces questions sans
aborder la question des indicateurs et
autre siz voilà donc tout ça est lié
simplement quand on parle d'infiltration
quand on parle de repenti on rentre dans
le cadre contrôle judiciaire si vous
voulez c'est sous le contrôle de
l'autorité judiciaire personnellement
j'ai eu j'ai instruit les dossiers
compliqués avec l'octrice avant de
partir à Eurojust je pense que si vous
voulez la la vraie question c'est que
pour moi les indicateurs ou les repentit
enfin les indicateurs ou les gens qui
travailleraient à la police il faut
créer un statut mais je l'ai défendu
mais ça n'a pas été soutenu par la
police je pense il faut créer ce que les
Américains ont c'est un collaborateur
occasionnel du service c'est faut une
vraie un vrai statut voilà et que laadea
les Américains si vous voulez on reste
parfois sur des situations genre
serpicot avec des gens infiltrés qui
font n'importe quoi en fait c'est
complètement under contrô si vous voulez
aux États-Unis avec toute une
jurisprudence toutes des règlements avec
des je veux dire entre guillemets un
contrat de travail avec quelqu'un qui a
des objectif et quand il dévie il tombe
voilà donc je pense que ça j'avais
espéré que les difficultés qu'il y a eu
en entre 2015 et 2017 aurait permis ce
genre de changement et de basculer dans
quelque chose de plus clair plus concret
de plus transparent alors transparent
pour la personne qui coopère transparent
pour le policier qui lui donne des
instructions aussi parce que
l'infiltration si vous voulez elle a un
avantage c'est que elle permet de
légitimer le travail du policier qui est
infiltré et qui commet des infractionsin
quand on fait avec l'indicateur et tout
tout est beaucoup plus trouble parce que
rien n'est autorisé judiciairement une
seule difficulté que je vois pour
l'infiltration mais elle est de taille
c'est-à-dire que autant pour la
procédure des témoins sous X c'est un
dossier secret qui est gardé séparé on
sait qu'il y a un C Mo sous X mais on n
pas toute la procédure je pense que
l'infiltration là o on a raté le coche
dans les lois perbes en 2004 c'est qu'on
l'a fait complètement transparente
c'est-à-dire qu'elle apparaît
complètement en procédure non pas
l'identité de l'infiltré mais on sait
qu'il y a eu une infiltration et ça
c'est dommage je pense que c'est c'est
compliqué de revenir dessus mais je
pense qu'il faudra avoir exactement la
même procédure que toutou le témoin sous
X où en fait dans le coffre fort bah il
y a la décision du JLD on sait pas dans
le dossier on sait qu'il y a un témoin
sous X mais normalement on sait pas qui
du tout et normalement on peut pas le
remonter parce que la procédure est
secérète et séparée et je pense que pour
l'infiltration ça serait pas plus mal
parce qu'en fait si vous voulez les
choses sont simple hein
euh quand on voyez qu'il y a une
infiltration euh si vous lisez bien les
les PV qui sont faits par l'agent
traéant et compagnie un vous doutez à
peu près de quel est le policier qui est
infiltré parce que les trafiquants l'ont
vu et de vous doutez un peu comment ça
s'est fait parce que c'est pas
l'infiltration mais je j'aurais pas
avoir l'air de d'exagérer mais
l'infiltration c'est pas voilà je suis
un policier je m'infiltre je vais à
Pigal le soir je rencontre deux
personnes dans un bar
c'est beaucoup plus avec des
interlocuteurs il faut qu'au départ il a
quand même quelqu'un qui soit proche des
trafiquants si vous voulez parce que
sinon on narrive pas comme ça dans un
bar pour s'infiltrer
voilà je suis prêt à répondre à toute
autre question sur les repen c'est un
vrai enjeu monsieur
voilà mais ça suppose aussi alors pour
être très clair qu'on veut y mettre des
sous parce que pour parler un peu
vulgairement c'est-à-dire que recréer
une vie à quelqu'un à toute sa
famille ça c'est un vrai coûp voilà
c'est pas c'est des opérations qui sont
chères et puis il faut avoir la culture
qui va avec les Italiens long monsieur
le présidentavel Marie Laur finera Orte
une question merci président bonjour à à
tous alors Monsieur touvenau Je voulais
vous poser une question depuis quelques
temps les criminels italiens embauchent
des migrants qui ont traverser la
Méditerranée je veux parler des
Nigérians en échange d'un voyage en
Guyane afin de transporter la drogue ils
obtiendraient des papiers pouvez-vous me
dire ce que Eurojust peut faire pour
enrayer ce trafic pas seulement de
drogue mais aussi
humain si vous voulez ce qu'on va
peut-être faire c'est prendre les deux
questions ça et sont
li oui merci beaucoup ces questions sont
liées alors je je me présente moi je
suis sénateur des bouche duô et élu de
de Marseille qui défraie souvent la
chronique pour malheureusement ses
affaires de drogue mais hlas ça concerne
toute la France et comme ma collègue on
a ce trafic notamment de de de mineurs
enfin de ce qu'on appelle mineur non
accompagnés qui sont souvent pas mineurs
et mais toujours accompagnés parce
qu'ils sont sont au proid de trafiquant
on ne vient pas de si loin sans être
accompagné notamment par des trafiquants
d'êtres humains et qui utilise beaucoup
ces jeunes qu'il déplace dans la France
pour
différents pour différents postes dans
le le narcotrafic je voulais savoir
effectivement avoir la même c'est la
même question que ma collègue mais ça
concerne pas la Guyenne ça concerne la
France
métropolitaine sur ces personnes qui euh
qui sont qui sont étrangers souvent de
façon entré de façon illégale en France
euh et qui sont au proid de ces
trafiquants dernière dernière question
d'olivier cadiic et puis du coup vous ce
sera votre dernière série de
réponse merci monsieur le Président oui
on parle vous avez parlé mentionné donc
la Guyane avec le Brésil le Brésil n'a
pas les gens n'ont pas besoin de visa
pour venir pour quelques jours en
vacances en France et là encore il y a
10 jours il y a eu un assassinat d'une
brésilienne donc avec deux autres
personnes qui ont été arrêtées au moment
o ell s'apprêt à reprendre l'avion pour
pour le Brésil elles ont témoigné l'une
27 ans qui dit qu'elle a trois enfants
une mère malade d'un cancer la pluie a
détruit sa mais maison elle a des dettes
elle demandait évidemment de comprendre
sa situation l'autre dit effectivement
j'ai une dette envers une personne qui
m'a menacé je m'excuse elle venait du du
Brésil on voit bien que ce sont les
petites mains du crime qui sont envoyées
vers vers la France qui sont utilisés
instrumentalisés euh quand j'étais au
Brésil nos collègues brésiliens nous ont
dit qu'il fallait que on travaille sur
ces questions la main dans la main
puisque c'est une problématique je
dirais c'est les deux faces d'une même
pièce et on le on le voit comment est-ce
que vous vous envisagez euh Eurojust de
travailler avec vos collègues par
exemple brésiliens sur ces dossiers
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
effectivement que bah ces petites mains
doivent aussi bien être protégé puisque
là actuellement c'est ce qu'ils
expliquent c'est qu'ils ont des menaces
sur leur propre vie donc comment est-ce
qu'on peut envisager ça et puis dans une
audition précédente il nous a été dit
que toutes les demandes de notre parquet
à Hong Kong revenait sans réponse euh
donc pour euh pour les affairire donc de
blanchiment et je vourrais savoir si on
était le seul pays européen dans ce cas
merci alors je vais répondre tout de
suite mariearl Carlotti du coup tout oui
merci je pensais pas déclencher les
questions je vais être question ce a
c'est qu'après voyez-vous je risque
d'oublier les premières donc je vais
essayer de r mais les questions de mes
collègues tout à l'heure ont montré
qu'effectivement comme vous l'évoquiez
tout à l'heure c'est la criminalité au
quotidien qui dérange les gens mais mais
je pense que la le haut du spectre
principalement responsable aussi parce
que c'est eux qui fournit tout ça ah
mais c'est pas moi qui vais vous dire le
contraire voilà mais je sais vous l'avez
dit et donc moi je voulais vous
interroger sur cette question notamment
sur la coopération vous avez parlé de
coopération c'est bien votre travail
est-ce que on on pourrait progresser en
matière de coopération notamment en
matière d'échange de données même si
certaines sont protégées même si est-ce
que au moins au sein des pays européens
on a encore des efforts à faire pour
échanger nos données pour échanger les
connaissances pour faire des enfin des
des pour avoir progresser sur ce secteur
ben je réponds tout de suite à votre
question non sur l'échange de données en
fait au niveau européen ça pose pas de
difficultés enfin je si vous voulez on a
créé alors notamment
Eurojust supporte une création qui a été
ce qu'on appelle le fichier terro
européen c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
échanges de données judiciaires entre
pays ça c'est pas dit qu'un jour ça
pourrait pas être fait pour la
criminalité organisée hein c'est-à-dire
que pour bon
euh pour l'instant si vous voulez euh si
les fichiers ça prend du temps pour les
créer c'est pas à vous que je vais le
dire non non seulement au niveau
français mais après au niveau européen
bon moi je pense que l'échange
d'information si vous voulez il
fonctionne au travers de tous les
réseaux parce que dans dans ces matières
ce qu'il faut voir moi je l'ai vu avant
quand j'étais magistrat national les
gens restent souvent les mêmes si vous
voulez donc en fait on connaît les gens
hein il y a il y a aussi une une
dimension personnel et les échanges ils
existent sur les euh sur les différentes
données sur les aspects des dossiers bon
tout ça en essayant de rester
opérationnel et pas
trop lointain je pense que ça ça existe
alors si vous voulez quand je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure que on allait sans
doute créer au niveau européen un réseau
de tous les procureurs spécialisés en
matière de criminalité organisé ce qui
existe pour les procureurs spécialisés
en matière de cybercriminalité c'est
tous ces forums en fait si vous voulez
ces forums qui sont
entre purement théorique le stratégique
et l'opérationnel en fait il y a des
gens qui ont les qui ont un peu tout qui
réflé chissent qui vont un peu des qui
ont une vision plus large et qui en même
temps échangent parce qu' il restent
liés dans les procédures moi ce que je
crois toujours c'est que tout ça doit s
doit être fait par des gens qui sont sur
le terrain et qui peuvent anticiper
voilà pour que ça reste pas théorique je
pense que ça les change de données
juridiquement parlant c'est pas une
difficulté quand il y a une volonté
voilà
alors sur le problème avec le le Brésil
si vous
voulez Hong Kong on est non alors vous
avez fait Hong Kong on n'est pas les
seuls voilà c'està-dire c'est pas c'est
pas aussi simple que ça mais c'est comme
si je vous parlais de chipreenord
aussi voà chypreenord je vois que ça
éveille chez vous quelque chose oui
Chypre est divisé en deux il y a la
partie et il y a la partie chypreenord
si vous avez quelqu'un qui est à
chypreenord on va vous dire que les
Turcs vont vous dire c'est pas chez nous
il faut envoyer puis chypreenord vous
dira qu'ils sont pas compétence c'est la
Turquie donc si vous voulez on peut rien
faire à Chine Hong Kong c'est c'est un
peu compliqué aussi mais je p je pense
qu'après il y a un vrai travail de fond
avec certains pays mais c'est c'est
clair ce n'est pas que la France qui a
des problèmes avec Hong Kong sur le
Brésil alors si vous voulez dans la
région on a aussi le Surinam avec lequel
c'est complexe de coopérer or le Surinam
si vous voulez constitue il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens qui passent en Guyane
qui sont du Surinam largement autant
voir plus que du Brésil bon sur place on
a alors je crois que l'année dernière il
y a eu déplacement au Surinam pour
essayer de favoriser la coopération avec
le
Surinam au brés
on a sur la région on a un magistrat de
liaison alors c'est vrai que le Brésil
c'est pas un état facile à coopérer
parce que c'est très grand c'est un État
fédéral et c'est complexe voilà je je
l'ai connu comme juge d'instruction je
peux vous dire maintenant oui j'espère
qu'il y a une volonté de coopérer des
Brésiliens sur ces questions alors pour
répondre un peu à toutes vos questions à
vous aussi mesdames en fait ce qu'il
faut si vous voulez pour quejus
s'agisse il faut qu'il y a un procureur
ou qui prenne la main sur un dossier s
puis qui a envie d'en faire aussi un
dossier européen avec des besoins de
coopération nous on peut pas enfin on
peut on peut un peu c'est ce qu'on
appelle notre initiative propre si vous
voulez c'est-à-dire que je pourrais
décider éventuellement d'ouvrir un
dossier sur ces questions mais si vous
voulez c'est les autorités nationales
qui enquêtent c'est la police française
ou la gendarmerie qui fait les enquêtes
il faut à un moment qu'il y ait une
vraie procédure quoi après si vous
voulez c'est c'est ces dossiers qui en
fait combinent aussi bien le narcotrafic
l'aide au séjour irrégulier
l'immigration clandestine c'est aussi
imigration clandestine ça fait partie
des gros dossiers européens qu'on a
puisque tout ce qui concerne la Manche
avec ce qu'on appelle les small boat les
petits bateaux si vous voulez c'est
toujours les mêmes pays hein qui sont
concernés l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas la
Belgique la France et l'Angleterre
d'accord donc là on a des sous-groupe de
travail aussi pourquoi parce que
toujours les mêmes questions avec les
problèmes juridiques qu'on peut avoir
avec l'Allemagne sur cette question
c'est que par exemple pour l'association
de malfaiteurs c'est complexe chez eux
le fait d'acheter des bateaux
pneumatiques en Allemagne et de les
avoir c'est pas une infraction il faut
le relier avec le reste des le reste des
dossiers mais eux considèrent que leur
leur aide au séjour irrégulier si vous
voulez pour parler de trafic
d'immigration il faut que ça soit vers
un pays de l'UE le départ des Anglais a
fait qu'ils ne sont plus dans l'UE c'est
évident donc en fait pour l'infraction
n'existe plus pour les Allemands quand
les gens vont en Angleterre à la fin
voilà donc ça il y a des réformes si
vous voulez qu'on voit au jour le jour
hein ça tout le monde le sait après vous
êtes bien placé pour le savoir c'est pas
toujours aussi simple que ça on sait
bien ce qui manque mais pour trouver euh
et mettre en place la loi qui va
permettre de combler ce gouffre c'est
pas toujours aussi simple donc voilà
nous notre travail c'est tout ça c'est
essayer de trouver des solutions on
arrive sur les dossiers d'immigration
les dossiers de stupéfiance je dirais
que souvent c'est c'est pas que c'est
plus simple mais tout le monde a des
intérêts conjugués quand on rentre dans
les dossiers d'immigration clandestine
ça n'aura échappé à personne qu'il y ait
une sensibilité parfois particulière
dans les états et trouver les
arrangements pour que tout fonctionne
dans le même sens c'est pas toujours
aussi Simp voilà mais ça fonctionne
normalement ça fonctionne et on est là
pour mettre de l'huile dans les
rouages merci merci beaucoup monsieur
touvneau de votre disponibilité puis de
la qualité deses échanges c'est
normal